la solidaridad de los libaneses está
reconstruyendo beirut después del
reguero de destrucción que dejó la
explosión en el puerto a principios de
mes desde cirugías plásticas hasta
asistencia psicológica
los profesionales libaneses han ofrecido
sus servicios gratuitamente pese a la
profunda crisis financiera que ha
devastado la economía de la nación una
forma de iniciar el proceso de sanación
de las víctimas de la tragedia
me gustaría que estas cicatrices
desaparecieran un día pero si no lo
hacen no me importa veo niños pequeños
que tienen cicatrices mucho peores que
las mías niños con una larga vida por
delante que tienen cicatrices más
desagradables en sus corazones en sus
almas guardarán este miserable recuerdo
con ellos para siempre
apenas horas después del estallido y con
el olor a cenizas aún en el aire cientos
de voluntarios sacaron sus escobas y
palas para limpiar los escombros de las
calles de beirut ofrecieron alimentos y
cobijo a aquellos que habían perdido sus
hogares más de 300.000 personas fueron
los primeros en responder a la
emergencia antes de que la
multitudinaria ayuda internacional
llegara al país y ante el vacío
gubernamental los mismos hombres y
mujeres que tomaron las plazas durante
las manifestaciones antigubernamentales
ahora estamos desempeñando el papel del
estado el gobierno debería hacer el
trabajo que estamos haciendo pero lo
estamos haciendo porque tenemos que
hacerlo si hay una manera de ayudar a la
gente por supuesto que lo haces no
puedes ver que necesitan ayuda y no
hacer nada
[Música]
los supervivientes se enfrentan ahora a
la gigantesca tarea de reconstruir sus
hogares negocios y cerrar las heridas de
un país asolado por las múltiples crisis